the rallying Cry of democracy has been
heard from tens of thousands of
protesters across Israel after the
knesset took away the Supreme Court's
power to strike down government
decisions
but in Tel Aviv anti-occupation
protesters are challenging this concept
everyone who's willing to say there is
no democracy without addressing the
occupation it's working here together
the block of protest groups say more
Palestinians are joining and talking
about their lack of basic rights words
like apartheid are starting to enter the
general mainstream conversation and even
leadership that are very classic
zionists are talking in these terms of a
regime you know you need a regime change
it's not just about democracy it's more
about
settlements or settlers Coupe now you
can see that the settlers are in the
knesset you have ministers indigenous
who live in settlements and now with the
laws they are giving you can really
understand this kind of book they're
just talking about annexing the West
Bank some Palestinians wear pictures of
watermelons the same color as a
Palestinian flag where waving one can
lead to arrest
this anti-occupation block challenges
the idea that Israel is a democratic
State they say so long as Palestinians
are denied their full rights inequality
and democracy cannot exist together
one former Israeli soldier says the
issues of occupation and democracy
cannot be disconnected and we think this
is our role especially as former
soldiers who serve in the occupied
territories to make sure that our
society is not limiting the discussion
the discourse over what is a democracy
to the judicial the Judiciary only the
Constitutional law professor says
between 1948 and 1992 Israel appeared
like a democracy with free elections but
lacked respect for the rights of
Palestinians that was the consequence of
the lack of any Bill of Rights or
mechanism that would restrict the
government from discriminating against
the Arab population he says in the 90s
the knesset created a set of basic laws
to respect human dignity the Supreme
Court ruled to enforce this the court is
empowered to review both governmental
actions and acts of technicid to make
sure that are in line with this
commitment
s the soul of democracy is being eroded
while many Palestinians here say their
rights and dignity have never been
respected and the basic laws supported
by the Supreme Court have not served to
protect them
Laura Khan Al Jazeera Tel Aviv